[موسيقى]
الحقيقه الكلام اللي قلته كمان فكرني
بالرحله اللي مر بيها الواحد في الفتره
اللي فاتت كلها وزي ما انتوا قلتوا الواحد
برض مر بكذا طريق ومشي في كذا حته بس
بتتكلم اكلمت على النجوم وعلى الناس بتبدا
ازاي تدور على طريقها في الصحره زمان فانا
قررت ان احنا بي مبسوط معاكم بحبكم كلكم
خكم معايا في رحله نرجع بيه بالزمن لورا
فتركوا معيا قت الزمن اللي موجوده دلوقتي
على السكرين هنسافر مئات السنين عشان نرجع
بالزمن اللي ورا عندنا كم مشكله ويز اخد
رايكم فيها من الناس راكبين معانا في حد
عنده صداع
وللاسف واحده زميلتنا كمان طلعت معانا
بطنها
وجعاها تفتكروا نعالجهم ازاي بس كمان بما
ان عندنا مشاكل دي فاحنا عايزين حد نرجع
لكل شويه لما يكون في اي مشكله بنواجهها
اي مشكله طبيه عايزين نروح نتكلم معاها
ونجعله ف الحقيقه حد من الموجودين حاليا
قاللي حل صداع معروف جدا احنا زمان هنمسك
الشخص نجيب دماغه
وحرقها سهله قوي صح في اي مشكله فيح نحرق
دماغ حد مافيش مشكله بس حقيقه مش كل الناس
تبص موضوع الحرق لان الشخص صديقنا كان
مصدع هو ما بيحبش النار فقلق منها فحد
تاني قالله الموضوع بسيط جدا هنجيب راسك
وهنجيب مسمار وهندو المسمار في راسك تمام
فصدع هيروح منطقي يا
جماعه بس وكان بعد كده قلنا طب هتعالج
الناس فين فالحقيقه لقينا واحد عطار هنروح
له كلنا كل ما حد يتعب هروح للعطار دوت هي
ما ينفعش صح ما ينفعش خالص مع ان على فكره
احنا فعلا بالمناسبه ده مشش هزار جد الناس
فعلا في مراحل كتيره من العمر من التاريخ
كان علاج الصداع وده فعلا بش هزار كان
بيضربوا مسمار في راس الناس وده كان
بيتعالج جوه
في في العصور اليونانيه القديمه والحقيقه
لقوا جماجم كتير قوي مخروم راسها ان هم
فعلا كان بيعالجوا الناس بهذه الطريقه
وكانوا احيانا بيقولوا ان ده طريق عشان
الشيطان يخرج برا الراس لان الصدا جا من
الشيطان وفعلا كان في ناس بيحرقوا راسهم
عشان دي طريقه بان يخلوا المخ يعني يستعد
ان يعني يسخن ويخرجوا منه اي الام فبيح
لقوا راسه وفعلا لفترات طويله قوي العلاج
بالديدان ده مشهور جدا كان موجود عند
العرب وكان بيقولوا ان الديدان دي وعلى
فكره لغايه دلوقتي في ناس بتستخدم العلاج
ده ان الديدان بتمص
الدم الدم الفاسد في الجسم فبت سعد على
العلاج من كل الامراض الموجوده لكن لما
نقول الكلام ده دلوقتي اصبح غريب جدا مش
هينفع نستخدمه مش هينفع يكون دلوقتي
بنتكلم عنه لان دلوقتي في طب في طب حديث
في اجهزه في تحاليل وفي اختبارات وفي علم
بيقول لنا بريسايسلي بالظبط هو ايه المرض
وازاي نقدر نعالجه بيقول لنا بالضبط ايه
الدوا والعلم تطور بس الحقيقه مش علم
الصيدله بس اللي تطور ولا علوم الفيزياء
ولا الكيميا كمان العلوم الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه
اطورت زمان لما كنا بنشتغل في الفلمنت او
الناس بتسميها مجال التنميه والمجال
الخيري كان تركيز الناس دايما على الهاو
على ازاي ننفذ المشروعات ودايما لما كنت
تقعد تقول انا هحل مشكله زي البطاله ازاي
كان بيقعدوا مجموعه من الافراد يقعدوا
يخططوا يقولوا احنا مثلا هنعمل تدريب
للشباب عشان يجهزه سوق العمل او مثلا احنا
هندي قرود للناس عزول العمل او غيره وغيره
وغيره صح بس الحقيقه زمان كان ممكن يكون
ده مقبول زي بالضبط ما كان زمان عاد ان
احنا نروح لعطار عشان يعالجن دلوقتي لو حد
مريض وراح لعطار غالبا كنا نقوله ده غريب
جدا صح ده نفس الكلام في التنميه بالضبط
الحقيقه مش مقبول انك تروح او تعتمد على
افكارك وعلى الجود
انشن الموضوع اكتر من نوايا حسنه دلوقتي
العلم بيكلمنا عن نركز على الواي ليه احنا
عايزين نعليك ده وعلى الوا ايه الهدف
بتاعنا وعلى الهاو ازاي ننفذه ومش بس كده
كمان على هو عشان مش هينفع ان احنا نحط
نفس الطريقه ونفس العلاج لكل شخص بكل
حاجه
والحقيقه في كتب كتير قوي وعلماء كتير قوي
اتكلموا عن دوت منهم كتب بنصحكم بشده
تقروها انا بحبها جدا زي كتاب بور
ايكونومكس او مور ج انشن او د ج بتر وكتاب
كمان من احلى الكتب اللي انا قرتها اسمها
سك اجين كلها بتكلم قد ايه احنا محتاجين
نفكر بشكل مختلف ازاي نقدر ن ماكسيمايز
الامباكت بتاعنا ازاي نعظم الاثر بتاعنا
كبني ادمين عشان خاطر نقدر يكون لنا اثر
كبير في الحياه وكمان في ادوارنا
ومسؤولياتنا
كافراد فالحقيقه الموضوع خلاص ما ينفعش
يتاخد بسهوله وبساطه زي زمان بس عشان ناخد
قرار صح تفتكر ناخده ازاي نعتمد على
خبراتنا الشخصيه كادنس
كافي تفتكروا نعتمد على اللي بنشوفه
بعينينا عشان نطمن ده شفناه بعينينا فهو
ده
الحقيقه ولا نعتمد على المعرفه اللي احنا
اتعلمناها وطورنا وجمعنا في السنين الخبره
اللي فاتت عندنا شويه اسئله تعالوا نفكر
مع بعض ونحاول نجاوب
خلاص اول سؤال بنساله هو ليه امريكا اللغه
الرسميه بتاعتها هي
الانجليزيه وسؤال التاني
هو قبل والت ديزني ما يعمل الشخصيه بتاع
بتا ميكي ماوس قبل ما ارسمها كان بيشتغل
ايه والسؤال التالت
هو هو ليه الاطفال لما بتاكل حلويات
بتهيبر الفي بتاعها بغير تبقى كده متنرفزه
ومتعصب وتعمل شقاوه فيش اي س و يعني نقدر
نرجع
لكتاب كتب كتير حقيقه ممكن ابعكم يرش ب
تقول الكلام ده مافيش اي سكدس بيقول ان في
اي علاقه كوريشن حتى مش كالتي ما بين
السكر واستخدام السكر وان الاطفال
يتعاملوا او يعملوا سلوكيات فيها نشاط
زايد او فيها شقاوه او غيره فيش اي اثبات
علمي عن كده انا اتخضت الحقيقه معرفت ده
وق اقول اكيد ده غلط فالحقيقه ق ادور كتير
جدا وق تى كميه بيبرز غير طبيعيه في الاخر
لقيت فعلا مافيش اي اثبات علمي على ده
كانت بالنسبه لهم فاجاه وبالمناسبه اللغه
الانجليزيه مش اللغه الرسميه لامريكا
امريكا ما عندهاش لغه الرسميه وبالمناسبه
والت ديزني م رسمش ميكي ماوس ل كان في
شخصيه تانيه خالص رسم اصلا ميكي ماوس مش
هو اللي
رسمه المعلومات دي بالنسبه لنا كلها غريبه
جديده احنا غير اللي احنا بنسمعه الحقيقه
ماتخدش قوي ده مش
غريب كتير قوي من معلوماتنا بنسمعها من
الناس حوالينا وبنسمع من ناس اتعلمناها
واحنا ماشيين في
حياتنا
فالحقيقه مش كتير من المعلومات او اللي
احنا اتعلمناها سنا رحلتنا بتكون دقيقه او
صحيحه او
علميه فمهم جدا ان احنا ما نعتمد على
المعلومات دي لانها مش دايما تكون صحيحه
الا لو متاكدين بشكل علمي
عليها خلاص انا عندي حل تاني زي ما قلنا
كده نعتمد على اللي بنشوفه بعينينا
اوكي فنشوف بقى اللي هنشوفه بعينينا
دلوقتي فعايز اللي شاف الفستان ده
فاكرينه الفستان ده اللي
شايفه ازرق في اسود يرفع ايده من
فضلكم اوكي شكرا نزلوا ايديكم حضراتكم
اللي شايفه ذهبي في ابيض يرفع ايده
بفضلكم طب ما نتفق يا جماعه هو مين الصح
احنا من 2015 احنا قدنا كده كم سنه ممان
سنين مش عارفين نتفق صح ده عادي تماما مش
بس كده الحقيقه في اختبارات كتيره جدا
موجوده تقدروا توصل لها زي مثلا مكي بزنس
وغيرهم هتلاقوا ان دايما او حتى انت تشوف
نفس النموذج ونفس الحاجه الاتنين بيشوفوها
قدام بعض وتلاقوا حاج بيشوفها بتلف في
اتجاه عارب الساعه وحد تاني خالص بيشوفها
في عكس اتجاه عارب الساعه لكن ده عادي جدا
بمعنى ان احنا ممكن نكون اتنين موجودين في
نفس الموقف بالضبط بنشوف نفس الحاجه
بالظبط واحنا الاتنين ليتر بنشوف عكس بعض
ويمكن في كتير بيتكلموا على ان لو انت
الفص الايمن بيكون شغال عندك بتشوف حاجات
معينه بشكل مختلف عن لو ان الفصل الايسر
هو اللي بيشتغل اكتر وه اللي بيسيطر اكتر
على طريقه تفكيرك ايه ده معنى كده ان احنا
ممكن نشوف نفس الحاجه تبقى قدام عينينا
وشايفها بعينيا وما تكونش مكن اكون غلط
وكون صح اه بدليل الفستان اللي عندنا اهو
هل حد فينا غلط لا معنا شايفين حاجات عكس
بعض بالضبط احنا شايفين في نفس اللحظه نفس
الصوره وشايفين عكس بعض
الحقيقه الصوره دي والفيديوهات اختبارات
الكتيره بتتكلم
على بتتكلم على اننا دايما كبني ادمين
عندنا مساحات من التحيز عندنا مشاعر عندنا
حواس ممكن تتحيز عندنا ستراكشن او تشتيت
ممكن يحصل للحواس بتاعتنا بتاثر شكل كبير
على طبيعه الحاجه اللي بشوفها هل معنى كده
ممكن يكون حاجه قدامي حد يشوفها كويسه حد
يشوفها وحشه ورد جدا هل ممكن اسمع صوت
اسمعه حاجه عكس اللي جنبي او غير اللي
جنبي اه طبعا عادي جدا في اختبارات كده
كتيره قوي عليه بتسمعوا نفس الحاجه بالضبط
انت بتسمع صوت والتاني بيسمع صوت تاني
خالص فالحقيقه ما نقدرش نعتمد على اللي
بنشوفه بعينينا عشان خاطر كمان احنا عندنا
تحيزات
كبشر طيب طب نعمل ايه ازاي نقدر نصرف حاجه
زي كده الاجابه هنا ان احنا محتاجين نعتمد
على السينك تولز الادوات العلميه والساين
فيك ايفيدنس وزي ما قلنا زي ما كنا زمان
بنفكر
وبنعترف الناس في راسها بالمسمار لو
مصدعين او غيره احنا كمان دلوقتي ودلوقتي
ما بنقبلش كده في العلوم الطبيه ومش ممكن
ناخد دوا ابدا غير لو تم اختباره مره انين
وع وطمنا ليه صح كمان في العلوم
الاجتماعيه مش المفروض نعمل كده ابدا الا
لما يكون في اختبار وتم اختبارها بشكل جيد
جدا واختبرها بشكل علمي والحقيقه نتيجه
لمجهودات الاف الباحثين في العالم دلوقتي
ب عندنا ايجابات لحاجات كتيره جدا فاكرين
من شويه المجموعه اللي قلنا عليهم قعدوا
مع بعض عشان خاطر يفكروا في حل لمشكله
البطاله بتاعه الشباب فقالوا احنا هنعمل
لهم تدريب عشان يجهزوا مسؤول العمل فاكرين
ده
دلوقتي احنا ما عندناش سكدس جوه مصر في كل
رانما كنترول ترايل او الابحاث العشوائيه
طلعت اي نتيجه ايجابيه لاجراء تجارب او
تدريب مهني على الشباب الذكور بنلاقي على
الاناث في بعض الحالات ولكن مالقيناش على
الذكور امباكت لغايه دلوقتي كمان القروض
فتره من فترات كانت الناس بتتكلم عن
الاقروض متنيه الصغر على انها هي الحل
السحري اي حد عنده فكره هياخد قرض هيقدر
يبدا زنس هيقدر يطور بيه هيعمل مشروع
سمعنا كير قوي بس السينك ايفيدنس ريسيرش
اللي عمل دين كارلين وكاس ماجير واس فلو
وغيرهم بعد ما عملوا اختبارات لدو في اكتر
من سبع دول في العالم ورجعوا اختبروها
بعديها عدد كبير من الباحثين مالقوش اي
اثر ايجابي للقروض متنيه الصغر التقليديه
التقليديه على تطور البزنس ما شفناش ده
بشكل سجك ولما شافوه شافوه بشكل قليل قوي
قوي قوي اده معنى كده ان العلم دلوقتي
بيقدر يقول لنا ايه اللي ممكن عمله وايه
اللي مش ممكن يعمله بالظبط بالظبط العلم
دلوقتي يقدر يجاوب لنا بريسايسلي على ايه
الانترنشنل انشطه اللي ممكن تساعدنا ان
احنا نعمل او نقدر نساعد بيها البشر على
خفض الفقر وايه اللي مش ممكن
نعمله كده احنا فكرنا وعرفنا ازاي نقدر
ناخد قرار هنبص على ساينتفيك ايفيدنس
صح بس هل ساينتفيك ايفيدنس ده الحاجه
الوحيده نا دلوقتي لما نبص على ساينتفيك
ايفيدنس هل هنقدر نحل الفقر بان احنا نجيب
موارد ويكون عندنا موارد كتير دايما
بنتكلم على الفقر الناس بتيجي تقول مافيش
فلوس عايزين فلوس اكتر لو في فلوس اكترر
هنعالج مشكله الفقر صح كده سمعت الجمله دي
قبل كده سمعناها كتير مش كده طيب الحقيقه
خليني اقوللكم ان انا مش موافق تماما على
الجمله دي وخليني اضرب مثال واحد لده
فمثلا في مجموعه اسمها اكتف ف او مجموعه
المسلمين الاسار الفعال وه جزء من موفمنت
كبير قوي اسمها اكت التزم وفيك التزم في
كريستيان في فجوز وفي حاجات ل مختلف
الديانات وفي كل حاجه ه مجموعه في الاخر
من العالم بيحاولوا يعني يتبرعوا يركزوا
تموتهم على القضايا ليها
اكبر نشر مقال الحقيقه في منتهى الجمال
كان بيقولوا فيه ايه كان بيقولوا فيه ان
تصور او الحقيقه الاشن طبقا الا حصيات
الرسميه لاجمالي تبرعات الذكاه للمسلمين
في العالم تساوي لقنوات الشرعيه الرسميه
قنوات الذكاه الرسميه 550 مليار
دولار
قنوات الشرعيه في الذكاه ده مش بيشمل
الصداقات مش بيشمل كمان انواع الذكاه اللي
احنا بنخرج بشكل عام في اي اي اي نشاط
خيري بنعمله 550 مليار دولار عارفين 550
مليار دولار اللي بس من المسلمين دي تقدر
تعمل ايه في السنه تعمل حاجات كتيره قوي
اكبر استميشن لقضاء على مشكله زي الجوع
اتكلموا على اننا محتاجين تقريبا 40 مليار
دولار في السنه لمده 10 سنوات من 2021 ل
2030 عشان عشان نقضي تماما على مشكله
الجوع اتكلموا كمان عشان نقضي على مشكله
الاكستريم بور او الاكستريم فرتي احنا
محتاجين او الفقره متقع محتاجين 350 مليار
دولار تعالوا بقى نصرف 350 مليار دولار
على 40 مليار دولار بنصرف على قضاء على
الجوع سنويا لسه متبق لنا فلوس كتيره قوي
550 مليار دولار لسه كمان الفلوس تخرج من
باقي الناس في العالم فالمشكله مش في
موارد المشكله الحقيقه مش في ريسورسز مش
فيز ابدا المشكله الحقيقه موجوده في
القرار بنصرف على ايه بنصرف ليه المشكله
ان في قرارات كتيره جدا من اللي احنا
وموضوعات كتيره قوي احنا ببعلها وبنصرف
عليها بنصرف عليها عشان احنا حبينا ده
عشان احنا حسينا ده عشان شفنا القضيه او
شفنا حاجه حسنها مهمه شفنا طفل بيقول انا
محتاج مساعدتكم فطلعنا فلوس تبرعنا بيه
ماعرفش بالضبط هل دي اكتر حاجه فلوس
بتاعتنا تكون مفيده ليها ولا
لا مشكله شغلت ناس كتيره جدا جدا في
العالم وفي كائنات كبيره زي جيف ويل وزي
عبد اللطيف جميلتي اكشن لاب وزي اكتز
موفمنت ركزوا على ان هم يحاولوا يجاوبوا
على السؤال دوت وان هم يساعدوا الناس في
ان هم يوصلوا لاكتر برامج واكتر مجالات
يتبرعوا بيها تساعدهم ان هم يحققوا امباكت
اكبر مش بس على مستوى الافراد اللي احنا
قلنا دلوقتي ان الفلوس اللي تبرع بيها
الافراد في العالم فلوس كبيره جدا جدا جدا
لو احنا قعدنا قدرنا نستفيد بيه ونستغل
بشكل صح هيكون لنا امباكت عظيم جدا ولكن
كمان على مستوى صانع
السياسات في قضايا كتير التعليم مثلا ازاي
نقدر نحسن بما ان التعليم الفقر جواه
مشاكل كتير زي فقر التعليم وفقر الصحي
وغيره في التعليم مثلا كان في سؤال زي
ازاي نحس مخرجات العمليه التعليميه اللي
هو مشكله احنا كمان بنواجهها في مصر وزي
الاجابه اكيد سمعتوها في مصر كتير كتير من
دول العالم فكروا فيها ان حل رقم واحد ان
احنا نزود مرتب المعلم كم واحد موافق على
دوت
اوكي الحقيقه اختبر التجربه طبعا في كتير
قوي كتير قوي بس اختبر كمان في احد دول في
اسيا اختها مجموعه من الاساتذه من هارفرد
باستخدام والحقيقه مالقوش
اي او
اي اي اثر ذ احصائيه مربوط ما بين زياده
الدخل دخل المعلمين اضعاف وتحسن مخرجات
العمليه التعليميه او تحسن درجات الاطفال
وعلمهم لكن طبعا المدرسين كانوا اسعد
طبيعي اي حد ياخد مرتب اكتر يا سعيد صح
احنا ما اختبرنا ده ما تمش اختباره في مصر
وده طبعا حاجه لازم يكون واضح فيها ولكن
كمان بيخلينا نشك في الفكره دي و بنشك في
ان مش بيعلمونا ان مش كل حاجه منطقيه او
نتصور انها منطقيه انها تكون فعلا ليها
اثر ايجابي على حياه
الناس عايز ارجع
تاني واقول الرحله دي كلها وسافرنا لورا
ورجعنا وان احنا نفكر في الناس اللي صدع
تطور حصل في عل الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه كل
ده عشان نوصل لنقطه ان احنا محتاجين نفكر
بشكل مختلف احنا كافراد احنا جو وظايفنا
احنا والمؤسسات اللي شغالين فيها
نق بتاعنا نقدر يكون لنا اثر نخدم ب عدد
كبير من الناس كل جنيه بصف اتبرع بيه ممكن
يكون عظيم لو احنا فكرنا بشكل مختلف لو
احنا بطرنا نعتمد
على
نفكر
زي ما احنا مستحيل ناخد اي علاج وناخد اي
دوا الا ما نشوف ونعرف ونطمن ان تم
اختباره تم دراسته بعنايه احنا كمان مش
المفروض نتبرع ونساعد او نتطوع حتى بوقتنا
الا في البرامج والاهداف والمدخلات مثبته
بشكل علمي احنا ما عندناش سبيل غير احترام
العلم وتقدير العلم ده الحاجه الوحيده
اللي هنقدر
بيه بتاعنا ونخ الفقر في العالم ان شاء
الله شكرا
[تصفيق]
جزيلا